[Applaudissements]
jama cornier oui parce qu'il ya très
très bon milieu de terrain attaquants et
ils vous annoncez un petit défi est ce
que voulaient voir ça ah oui c'est vrai
que ma lancée un petit elle regarde
c'est enfin j'ai ici un défi consiste à
toucher la barre transversale en se
mettant à peu près à 15 juin est
derrière la surface de réparation mais
nominés pour ce défi seront basse
baptiste reynet du fc lorient
cyril hanouna de touche pas à mon poste
notamment un grand amateur de football
donc à vos ballons et bonne chance de
vous dire déjà peint à la main c'est
maliki at the base à barres en bois il y
aura un joueur de lorient est un moment
cyril hanouna rapporté le cadrage est
pourquoi le gac et est donc j'ai été
faire ce ver relever le défi mais non
j'ai été faire lever essayé oui j'essaie
et ça marche bah oui vous avez des
images c'est vrai un coach de la
révolution tant d'europe champion du
monde sylvain wiltord va marquer le but
le but il nous envoyait au final près
qui nous a fait gagner sylvain wiltord
exactement il regarde ça c'est pour
benjamin voilà de de saint-etienne c'est
le défi de cyril hanouna bien sûr ouais
il est bon je suis comme ça moi je suis
venu clôture c'était mon coach j'ai dit
que ce qui arrive voilà talons fesses et
petit sac 8 pas tout de suite pas tout
de suite tu es trop pressé cb pichot
visualise la barre bien joué dommage pas
mal oui mais pas loin
ouais
c'est pas mal et laisse
[Musique]
1re série sur la première série
la mer c'est remercié alors je dois
décider maintenant
trois autres personnes pour ce défi donc
je vais désigné je vous le dis je vais
désigné jean-michel baer qui va devoir
essayer non coulis arnaud montebourg le
ministre de l'ecologie valeur c'est vrai
voilà alors il va il arrêté et on va
désigner allez on va désigner eux
non on va définir un animateur on va
désigner
vous savez quoi gilles bouleau le
présentateur du sud et est
on va voir s'ils vont le faire ça allez
on va accueillir tout de suite notre
invité est notre invité
c'est une jeune fille qu'on adore c'est
une de nos animatrices préférées parce
que maintenant on peut le dire est
animatrice 1 c'est christine accord